little squirt has generally been known
for DDoS distributed denial-of-service
attacks which have included some quite
high profile targets living on
PlayStation Xbox and obviously the lazy
ones malaysian airlines' their general
attack has been to bring awareness of
security or lack of security which is
their reason for doing things there has
been leaks of information generally they
say that it's raising awareness for
security measures you know for the
larger companies which are potentially
holding our data the relative
organizations the FBI and the likes you
know it's in their interest to ensure
that these people are caught and they
will go after them and they will almost
certainly catch them and that's when we
tend to see the whole group that sort of
go underground
you know just design try and cover their
tracks keep have the limelight for a
while and impossibly resurface as
somebody different or has a different
variation on that group these people are
well distributed are well hidden now
they're obviously good at what they do
you know and the very act of what
they're doing you know they will do
their absolute utmost to cover their
tracks in protect themselves I certainly
don't agree with how they do it it's
certainly wrong what they do in but um
yeah I mean if it isn't them it would
almost certainly be somebody else you
know they're they're sort of brain
currently at the top I certainly won't
last you know too long somebody else
will come along and take their place